hello everyone my name is me one I come
from microsoft research Asia the demo
I'm going to show you right now is a
junk Walker between Microsoft Research
Cambridge and Mike Rosario Tricia it
caught inside the cloud is to explore
the new interactions for cloud computing
so cal computing calls for the new UI
metaphors and new hardware technologies
to enable the more natural user
interfaces so club moss is one such of
this technology with chrome oz I can
access my data my information in the
cloud anywhere so here is a real demo
here you can see all those information
are rendered he like the universal
concept all those information on the top
all those new task I'm going to work on
right now today all those people's I'm
going to connect I'm going to
communicate today so I can sue me to say
what happened past and what going to
happen in the coming days I also can
switch to the side view to see all those
summaries for my job and my
communications I might ask so I came
back to the front view and can push into
my slack one task to see okay there how
many documents you need how many task I
need to work out so now choose all those
documents and the people's for these
tasks back to the home page and switch
to my home stereos sinkoff you help this
club moss and when you back to home you
want to see some of the entertainment
and some of those game some of those
pictures you take so now I drag this
picture a wall to the center and it
shows all those pictures and emo bride
views I can you declare miles 22
browsing age I also can switch to
another pictures to look into it to do
me into the mode detailed in from to see
more detailed information to see a big
picture and I can share this with my
friends so I just graduate share with my
friends and also i can drag these
pictures to share to another device so i
drag it share to this data frame so
summarize the damn a'ight just showed
today is the new interactions for cloud
computing thank you
you